okay good morning or with noon everyone
my name is a mint and we're gonna talk
about the natural language understanding
orchestra so first a few words about my
employer booking.com so you probably
know it's the biggest accommodation
website worldwide most of you probably
already use it what you probably haven't
used is our chat but we have a chat word
on facebook Messenger and you can just
search for at work income in facebook
Messenger and try to chat with us try to
book a hotel with us using plain and
natural English so I welcome all of you
to try this send feedback tell me how it
went I would really like to know so a
few words about myself I'm a senior or
machine learning engineer at booking and
in the past seven years I've been
working on mainly chat BOTS for the
travel domain first as part of a startup
then in the last two years as part of
booking and through this experience and
during this time I had accumulated a lot
of bugs and challenges and problems that
me and my team have seen so there were a
lot a lot of problems that we've faced
and a lot of challenges and I would and
I would like to share them with you I
would like to stress that it's not only
about chat BOTS so chat bots are one
type of a complex natural language
understanding or NLU product they might
be others summarization question
answering semantic search and each one
of them has a lot of models machine
learning models working in parallel in
order to achieve one goal and I want to
take you through this journey of what
problems we encountered and how we are
aiming to and and we are solving them
right now so we will start with a few
simple examples you know they
demonstrate the problems that we have
this is a simple query Hotel in were so
a very very simple sentence that the
user might might type in our chat bot we
want to understand this and we want to
serve them the best that we can so we do
the first thing that every machine
learning practitioner does with this we
tokenized the the data we try to take
this string of characters and split it
into distinct words so other components
along along the path we'll be able to
use these tokens and it would be easier
for them to understand tokens instead of
separate characters then we try to
understand what we see inside these
tokens so use it usually it's called
named entity cognition I will only focus
on one case of this the location parser
I want to understand which token is a
location which token is means what
location in the world so the token of or
so means this place right now with this
longitude and latitude and this number
of hotels such as such every data that I
can bring in from for my database and
and now I know which location the user
is talking about the next thing I'd like
to understand is what is the intent of
the user what do they try to accomplish
why did they come to the chat but in the
first place in this case we are talking
about searching for an accommodation so
given the given the intent and given the
location that I know now I can serve
some results to the user I can help them
I can show them the hotels that they're
looking for and now and and now they can
take their I bought some value some
useful value from my product so this is
a linear pipeline and virtually all any
new products start with this linear
pipelines one component passes the data
to another component and then another
one and so forth and I would like to
challenge this assumption I would like
to challenge this idea and I'll show you
why let's take a different example the
same one but in Italian Albert whoever
salvia if we see this we want to
understand the user still or at least
give them a proper feedback so usually
we will add as another component in here
language identification say if it's
English where we are using our current
pipeline but if it's not English we
might have a different pipeline we have
different to Canada
and different names for locations or
maybe we just don't support it and we
won't like to say sorry what we're not
supporting Italian so we have we already
have not a pipeline but a place where we
have to make a decision where we need to
take one path or the other path and in
this case this is linear but just almost
because we're starting to see the
complexity creeps in creeping in let's
look at the third example and the
example is a little bit more cheeky
cancel Eden hotel
personally I can read it read this in
two ways one where Eden is a city there
are quite a few cities with this name
and I'm saying okay the user is talking
about this city there is another way
which is but based on the fact that I
can identify the intent the intent of
this specific user is to cancel a
previous book in that they have on on
our website and when we do understand
that we want to give them the best
experience possible maybe they just
booked a room at a hotel called Eden
hotel like this and so I would like to
take the intent that they just
identified which use the location go
back to the location processor Intel and
tell it well maybe you can search a
little bit better now that we know that
is about cancellations maybe you can
look at the previous bookings of this
user maybe we you can understand the
sentence differently and now we have a
feedback loop in this and this feedback
loop complicates things so which should
I run first the intent classifier the
location processor which affects whom
how much time should they go with this
loop again and again until I think that
my results are correct so this makes
this makes it a little bit complicated
the last example I would give starts
again with a very very simple example
hotel in Cambridge we tokenize and
identify the location and the intent
seems easy enough and then we're saying
okay we assume this is Cambridge UK
because it's the most popular one we
don't want to bug the users with
more questions we just assumed this and
we shows we show some results for this
and then the user just types in
Massachusetts so we start again our
pipeline and we identify Massachusetts
as a state because I don't know if
anything else that sounds like this but
then we need to identify what is the
intent of the user what is the real
action that this user tried to achieve
they try to fix our results they try to
fix the location that we thought we
understood and saying no I meant
Cambridge Massachusetts not that
Cambridge this one and in order to
identify this intent we need to we need
to have another point of data this this
this data is the conversation state we
need to know that the user searched
already we need to know that we showed
results in UK and we need to know that
we might can interpret the location just
differently from what we understood also
the location parser needs to take the
conversation state into account because
the user they don't want a hotel
anywhere in Massachusetts they wanted
specifically in Cambridge Massachusetts
and we want to help them if I show them
the wrong thing they will go away and
for a good reason so there is a
conversation state that keeps in and
effect about the intent classification
they look and the location parser and we
can really see with our own eyes that
conversations do not behave like
pipelines where you have a very strict
order of things and one leads to another
and they are all sequentially and
happily Everafter you see we see a
different pattern here and this is the
problem that we encountered while trying
to to enrich and add more capabilities
to our product eventually this one
doesn't scale thinking of this as a
pipeline is problematic
okay so let's enumerate again the
problems that we've seen conversations
are nonlinear even people are talking
about multiple things they have multiple
threads of thought within the same chat
that pipeline metaphor is inherently
broken because things are not working
sequentially anymore they also have
multiple dependencies and a lot of
complexity of what take into account at
each stage and the same component is
called many times with different inputs
so when should we run it when should we
really use it and when should we say ok
we're done that's the problems that we
faced and I would like to to change our
point of view and look at this as a
different with different architectural
choices so first I will back away from
the pipeline and would say this is a
graph a graph has nodes a graph has
edges it can have multiple edges for
each node it can have loops it can have
a lot of stuff but it's not a pipeline
we are not talking about sequential data
anymore but still even that I flip the
image we didn't solve the initial
problem for example the location parser
is used in many ways by with many inputs
and in the end different stages so what
should we do about this how should we
handle this and here there is another
insight to be to be seen we have the
task of identifying locations but we
don't have to have one model that
identifies them we can have more than
one so maybe I can have one location
passer which only takes the tokens into
account and understands locations given
the text what it can what it can't
understand it won't do this and then I
have a different model it does the same
thing basically it tries to to
contribute results to the same task but
this model also assumes that it knows
the conversation state it knows the
intense maybe it knows the results of
the previous
location parser but now that we have two
models each of them have a clearer
dependencies we can move them around and
get to the state where we have a
directed acyclic graph and this Doug for
short is very powerful because this kind
of graphs have the pelagic call order
they have natural order I know what can
be run at each stage I know that if I
get to a specific node in the graph
everything that it depends on R is
already completed or ran or something
else so I can really look at this and
reason what am i doing how my flow looks
like and what exactly I need to run at
each stage so with this let's try to
break down while I'm actually proposing
for you as a solution so first we need
to separate the tasks in two different
models if I have different dependencies
I want to have different models for them
I don't have to treat each task as being
tied to one specific model or to one
specific method so I can have a location
processor that uses tokens one that uses
intents and one that uses the
conversation and they're all
contributing to the same result
eventually which is which locations I
identified the second thing is we start
to define some kind of standard contract
between different components let's take
the example of the intent to fix the
previous location it has dependencies
and these dependencies are not just
locations in general we want to say we
want the simple location parser we
wanted the English tokenizer to be on
before it and we want to have the
conversation state without these three
components we cannot run only we might
have a condition for the first message
there is no need to run this we can skip
it basically and we have the output and
the output is what we return basically
to the graph and accumulate over time
and it has two dimensions
this output it has the type which is the
label and it has the let's call it the
result to wish to fill out the slot wish
to fill which is the intent of the user
and by doing this separating the type
from the from the result or from the
task that we are trying to accomplish we
can now have a standard API between
components each component outputs one
type of results so I've enumerated a few
of them tokens for example are just the
words maybe with some added data is it
singular is it plural is it misspelled
whatever spans are basically spends of
of different tokens that I that have
some value so in our case eden Hotel is
a span of two tokens and the type of it
is a location and the value is this
specific hotel with a hotel ID and all
the data I can put from the database we
have labels which are pairs that apply
to the whole text we've seen intent
which is a boolean label which means the
user whether the user wants to book a
hotel or not but we also have some
labels with a lot of a lot of data for
example sentiment analysis I can have a
label which says how much the user is
angry or happy with the results have
shown them maybe I'm I'm showing them
I'm showing them a hotel and I'm asking
did you like it
so I want to identify want to classify
this and I want to have this on a scale
and we have the state the state contains
what we previously understood but also a
lot of metadata around the user that we
can achieve so for example if user says
I want a hotel for tonight it's really
important for us to understand which
time zones they are in whether they're
in China or in the u.s. it's two
different days and we don't want to book
them the hotel for tomorrow and they
will come to the author and see oh I
don't have reservation for today
in the middle of the night
so we have this standardization of of
the API now the components can be freely
connected and disconnected one to the
other and it's certainly easy to change
the GAF according to what we need the
last part of the proposed solution is
basically some kind of Orchestrator or a
conductor this component is special in
that it gets the configuration of the
whole graph and then it runs the models
one by one according to their
topological order according to the
conditions they have and passes just the
data from one to another according to
what they configure as the dependencies
so this this part is in my view very
similar to just a plain web server that
just routes the traffic between each
model until we complete the request so
this is the solution that I did I
proposed these are the aspects of it and
I would like to argue that it has many
many advantages
the first merits of it are on the
software architecture world this is
basically a micro service architecture
we can call it micro model we can call
it in many names but it has the same
advantages that we all see when we are
developing and deploying micro services
monolithic monolith discs are obsolete
in many ways and by this way we have
very defined components one can use
tensorflow the other one can use PI
touch the third one can use a different
technology or a different version we
don't have to to argue which one is
better and try to cram them all into one
process also it's very easy to unit test
so think about this I have a component
it should identify locations I know
exactly what tests I want to use what is
the output that I expect I can verify
that by itself each component works
correctly and this is very powerful and
really contributes to my development
velocity and the third one is that it's
easy to check errors to the specific
components so maybe I've seen that we
didn't apply correctly to the user but
we so I'm looking at this and saying Oh
did we identify the the intent correctly
it seems not so let's take a step back
let's look let's look at the inputs that
this intent classifier got are they're
all correct if so then I know that this
component is is the one to blame or the
one to fix but if one of them was
incorrect I can go further backward and
backward until I can find the root cause
of my problem and see how it propagates
through the graph from one error which
might not be big how it propagates to
something that the user didn't want us
did not want to see and we did not want
to reply there are another set of
advantages there are more Oken around
the machine learning and product
practition so it's really hard to write
good models I've tried a lot and while
tokenize as a pretty simple location
purses or intent classifiers are
notoriously hard to tune and the reason
about and collect data for and when I
have a good location processor or a good
passer of any other kind I want to share
it with everybody I want to share it
within my team with different products I
want to do to make it useful for as many
people as I can and by separating my
mother's to a very specific standard
api's I can really foster reuse of them
also it's very easy to extend and be
flexible I have a chat bot but booking
also have a search box when you get when
you type booking.com you get a search
box they don't need the intent
classification they don't need to have a
conversation state they just want to
understand locations for example so you
just call a subgraph of my big off and
use it its results without calling the
whole thing it's easy to share the same
infrastructure also it's super easy to
extend think about this I have a big
hairy transformer intent classifier that
identifies hotel booking and hotel
cancellations and asking for customer
support and whatnot and now I see people
are coming to me
telling me you are awesome or you did a
good job there's sometimes say this to
the but it's very nice of them and I
want to reply them nicely I want to say
thank you I'm you're welcome I don't
know I want to reply with something
intelligent but I don't have the same
amount of data that I have for hotel
bookings and hotel cancellations I have
just a few a few examples that have seen
this but I still want to reply them
correctly so I don't need to now find a
lot of thousands of examples train my
big transformer model with tensorflow
tons of GPU time in order to carve some
space for this intent I can just say oh
I will just roll out a model which is a
regular expression when someone says
thank you or you're awesome or you were
great I will just apply to them of
something and I can put this model in
the gap a very simple model which is
basically two lines of regular
expression and I'm almost done I will
say this is high probability I can now
see how it affects the user how many
times it is called what happened with
these conversations were are applied
with that and if I see that I have more
data and I have more need for a more
sophisticated model I can just replace
it now I have 300 examples I can replace
do the circuit line model I have 3000
examples I can put another transformer I
don't know I don't have to be tied by my
task to a specific tool there is no
one-size-fits-all in language or in men
or in many cases in machine learning we
need to think that we we should be able
to take the right tool for the specific
job that we that we need to accomplish
so this kind of graph really gives us
the flexibility to try this it also
gives us the flexibility to experiment
freely if I have a good location
I haven't another location passer I'm
saying oh this is great I checked it and
it has a its f1 score is bigger by 5%
it's better on my offline data we should
use it why should we maybe we'll put
this and experiment with this we'll put
this inside the graph and now we will
direct we'll do a/b testing with
50% of the user through the old location
passer the other 50 through the new
location passer and let's see do users
book more our user seems to be happier
less angry do they do they look like
they found what they looked for if so I
can the offline magic really correlates
with my product but maybe it doesn't
affect it at all so this kind of graph
makes it easy to experiment and
understand how your offline improvements
of machine learning models really
manifest in the in your product so to
summarize I would like to reiterate what
I'm proposing as a solution we should
never look at complex and a new product
as just pipelines that transfer data
from one component to another they are
graphs and these graphs are made of many
models each one can be whatever
technology we want it's a service by
itself they are all contributing to the
same task these tests are very are well
defined they have dependencies and
conditions and they have standard output
so we can mix and match and eventually
what we need to do we have this very
simple straightforward models and just
one complex or subtly complex
Orchestrator that make sure that
everything turns in its turn and and get
and returns the result eventually so
thank you very much I will be happy to
get any feedback and any questions here
or later and if you face similar
problems feel free to contact me
[Applause]
thank you questions okay whew
the question is you propose I see click
graphs but is it in production yes we
have this in production question is how
big it is this graph like so so the
examples I've shown here are with four
models something like this in production
we have as part of the graph like twelve
or fifteen different models and we have
other models that we are currently
transferring into the graph that we
haven't been able to do so before two
more questions
someone here right yeah hello thanks for
the talk so I understood your our
solution as like okay handcrafted direct
classically graph with models specified
for some specific case with dependencies
how would you compare that approach to
an end-to-end approach where we would
try to solve the whole like because this
solution requires a human that would
model the stuff in a conceptual why
verse that we need an intent we need a
location and etc how do comparative like
an end-to-end approach where we would
try to like optimize some final metric
of the whole system without doing this
thank you for the question
so one option to optimize this kind of
this is a very for example that the task
of understanding users in order to help
them book an accommodation is a very
complex task and it's not always clear
what is the end goal so eventually they
should book more but if someone says is
this hotel wheelchair accessible and I'm
saying no it's not am i doing anything
wrong of course not but they will not
book because they need something that is
accessible so it's very hard to measure
this so I prefer to focus on specific
areas where I can that I can measure the
success in a way that is objective like
they understand the location and for the
product
I would try to optimize as software
metrics like people's happiness and
greenness how likely they are to convert
and see that this the product metrics go
up not the machine learning ones of
precision and accuracy in addition
regarding to end-to-end system I always
found it hard to retrain them and to
have different sizes of problems within
them so you have a very big big model
now each one needs to add a new intent
or add a new type of thing or we need to
tune something that's usually after the
end-to-end system you just have repairs
and repairs of you know handcrafted
regular expressions to make sure that
you didn't miss Paris or New York or
something like this one question last
one or someone here
great talk Thanks just for curious I'm
just curious how many different states
of the conversation you track you said
that there are boolean flags we are
trying basically to to understand what
is the current flow of the of the users
so for example maybe we are at the part
where the user tries to filter the
results that they've seen or maybe
another flow might be might be to really
specify what why they are going on
vacation or on a trip is this the
business trip and my question is about
the number of so basically each each
flow has a state machine and this state
machine contains usually like four five
states but it's they can they move from
flow to flow like according to whether
accomplish okay thanks okay thank you so
much for the talk and click applause
[Applause]